foreign
[Music]
Al episode we offer you a preview of a
somewhat unusual movie with an excellent
cast we are talking about Barbie from
Warner Brothers usually this is not the
kind of relief that would attract a lot
of attention from film fans but in this
case there are several factors that have
attracted a lot of interest in Hollywood
and Beyond find out everything about the
plot cast and production of the project
right now in this video enjoy
let's start with the story of Barbie
actually what is least known so far is
what plot the film follows we do know
that Barbie and Ken play the two leading
roles of course based on the official
images we can also guess that the movie
is taking place in a brightly colored
World some theories are already out
there including one or two quite
plausible ones which we can well imagine
in the finished film according to the
fictional biography of the world's most
famous doll Barbie's full name is
Barbara Millicent Roberts daughter of
George and Margaret Roberts of the
fictional town of Milos in Wisconsin in
an alternate narrative from Golden Books
Generation Girl book series Barbie
attended the fictional Manhattan
International High School in New York
City in addition to her many hobbies her
private life centers on her lover Ken
whose real name is Kenneth Carson
depending on the narrative the two have
an on off relationship broke up in the
2000s or even just neighbors or friends
since there is no definite backstory
here in theory the film could pick up on
any of these constellations Barbie's
family also include three younger
sisters named Skipper Stacy and Chelsea
as we've already seen from various
appearances of the siblings in adapted
movies or series she also has a variety
of friends who also change depending on
the stories particularly noteworthy are
Barbie's countless pets including exotic
animals like a lion cub or a panda but
also common pets such as dogs cats or
horses the same is true for her
professions for instance she does not
have one occupation but a different one
depending on the doll it would probably
be easier to tell which profession
Barbie has not yet pursued which is why
the filmmakers are given unlimited
creative freedom here as well as you can
see there are lots of possible ways of
combining Barbie's personal life but the
most important aspect is certainly the
question of a relationship with Ken
regardless of whether the two are lovers
have an open relationship or even just
friends the option chosen will have a
decisive impact on the plot of the film
especially since Ken is one of the two
main characters but more on that later a
second important factor comes into play
and that is the choice director her name
is Greta gerwick and in addition to
directing the film she also took on the
task of writing the script the
screenplay resulted from a collaboration
with filmmaker Noah bombach who for
example was the director of 2019's
marriage story and is actually married
to Gerwig Greta Gerwig herself has also
had a number of movies to her credit
including The Coming of Age movies Lady
Bird and Little Women Gerwig is quite
well known in Hollywood's Indie scene as
she enjoys telling stories that depart
from Classic Hollywood cliches while
making more out of seemingly
straightforward storylines then one
Might at first think the focus is
usually on a strong emancipated woman
who doesn't conform to the traditional
role model that was frequently portrayed
in films and television in the past all
in all this is pretty much the opposite
of what you would expect from a Barbie
movie adaptation but that's precisely
what makes it so interesting what
exactly her vision for the new Barbie
movie looks like it's still a matter of
speculation one thing for sure is that
she will have to pull off a major feat
to not only turn a lifeless toy doll
into an A-list movie but also give it
enough profundity to keep viewers from
leaving the theater and mass after 20
minutes if you consider who directed and
scripted this film it becomes apparent
that we are not dealing with a colorful
world full of Carefree platinum blonde
and silly Barbies but there's at least a
large portion of feminism between the
lines one indication of this is a scene
that has been passed down to us in which
Barbie hits a man for grabbing her butt
let's now deal with the only piece of
information that has already been
officially revealed on the movie's IMDb
page those responsible published a
single sentence about the story it
basically states that a doll is banished
from Barbie world for not being perfect
enough their Pawn she begins an
adventure in the real world an
unofficial continuation of the brief
synopsis can be found in a tweet by the
user at Jason ozia who elaborates on the
story a bit more he refers to
unconfirmed details about the movie's
storyline According to which Barbie
world is composed of a lot of Barbies
and a lot of kids the comedy then
quickly turns with the fish out of water
style he said the idiom refers to a
person suddenly having to cope in an
environment that is completely new to
them much like a fish out of water
cannon contrast is a runaway from Barbie
world and a complete idiot but he is
madly in love with Barbie unlike her he
loves the real world including the
ideals of Beauty in the prevailing
sexism last but not least Will Ferrell
and America Ferreira are to play
important parts in summary the film is
reported to be a mix of Greta gerwig's
Little Women the film Splash and The
Truman Show and a musical by Jacques
Demi in fact the unconfirmed details
provided by at Jason ozia are so far the
most credible information we have heard
regarding the film's plot
moving on to the cast of Barbie which is
probably the number one reason why there
is so much talk about the film first
there's lead actress Margot Robbie who's
known from films Like the Wolf of Wall
Street and her performance is Harley
Quinn in Suicide Squad and birds of prey
since her big breakthrough around 10
years ago she's become one of the most
sought after Hollywood actresses ever
and obviously fits the role of Barbie
perfectly she is certainly convincing
not only because of her appearance which
resembles the doll very much anyway but
also due to her gifted acting skills if
anyone manages to be convincing on both
sides it's probably Margot Robbie no
less well-known is the male star of the
film adaptation of course we are talking
about Ryan Gosling who is known from a
wide range of films including Drive La
La Land And Blade Runner 2049 there are
already images of him as well which have
also caused quite a bit of positive
publicity due to his iconic look he too
looks like a copycat of the male toy
doll and likewise possesses the required
acting skills to give the character the
necessary amount of depth as already
mentioned Will Ferrell will also be
playing an important part the legendary
comedian can add his personal
distinctive touch to almost any movie
he'll play the CEO of the US company
Mattel the manufacturer of the famous
Barbie dolls it is also certain that
simulu will play another can the Shang
Chi and the legend of the ten ring star
will probably be one of many cans sex
education actor nikuti gadwa Will embody
another version of the toy character as
well there are also confirmed castings
on the barbie side including the
lovebirds actress Issa Ray and Hari Neff
who is known from one up for instance
still unclear as the role of America
Ferreira who should be familiar to most
people from NBC's Superstore she
previously thrilled audiences in the
drama series Ugly Betty other unknown
roles are played by Michael Sarah Scott
Evans Kate McKinnon and Kingsley benedir
overall this is an extremely prestigious
cast that will no doubt be capable of
realizing the movie according to Greta
gerwig's ideas
finally let's take a look at the
production of Barbie in fact initial
work on a film Loosely based on the toy
character of the same name began as
early as 2009. this led to a cooperation
between Mattel and Universal Studios
which however did not result in anything
after that Sony Pictures attempted to
make a film adaptation and made
significantly more progress than its
competitor Universal however in this
case the deadline for the movie
adaptation expired in October 2018.
without a start of filming Warner
Brothers eventually took over the
project and has maintained it to this
day in July 2019 Margot Robbie was the
first to be signed on the creative
Direction was then finally taken over a
few months later by the Gerwig bombach
couple who thus succeeded Wonder Woman
director Patty Jenkins Gosling's signing
was just about a year ago prior to that
it was unclear who would play the role
of Ken sadly there's been no trailer or
other video footage yet but one could
already gain some First Impressions
through various pictures besides the
officially published snapshots of the
two main characters there are also
fairly new images from behind the scenes
both main actors can be seen in neon
colored and very gaudy roller skating
outfits on the beach for Margot Robbie
the outfit is said to have been one of
the most embarrassing moments of her
life as she herself confirmed on Jimmy
Fallon's show shooting was completed at
the end of July this year and the
release of Barbie is scheduled for July
21st 2023
now we hope you enjoyed our new original
generally speaking what are your
opinions on the ambitious idea of
turning an iconic toy character into a
feature film and can you think of any
other characters that might be worthy of
a film or series adaptation drop us a
line in the comments
foreign
[Music]